an in-house staff writer from the Trump
Organization is taking the blame for
Melania Trump's controversial speech on
Monday the first lady hopeful was
accused of plagiarizing part of her
speech from Michelle Obama in an
official statement released by the Trump
campaign
Meredith McIver takes the blame and
explains that when Melania read passages
from Michelle's original speech over the
phone as inspiration she wrote them down
but never actually checked the first
lady's speech MacGyver says she offered
to resign on Tuesday but Donald Trump
didn't let her but all eyes were on
another Trump at Tuesday night's
convention
Donald's daughter Tiffany it's so
amazing to be with you tonight and say a
few words about my father
people can't stop comparing the 22 year
old some Miley Cyrus oh I thought it was
a joke
just check out this side-by-side and
some of the tweets we found please
excuse me if I'm a little nervous when I
graduated college a couple of months ago
I never expected to be here tonight
addressing the nation